What is your cancer feeding off of? What's the fuel source? It's important to know that
Understand also that the fuel source can change so you might have to change your diet through your cancer treatment program
Now most cells feed primarily off of glucose through glycolysis
Through glycolysis glucose is broken down into pyruvate which then goes into acetyl coins
I may enter the Krebs cycle. You remember that from biology
I made a cancer's feed an aerobically that means the pyruvate breaks down into lactic acid and it feeds off of that
Rather inefficiently, but that's what happens with cancers. Now, there's a gene that converts pyruvate
to acetyl coins I may and many times defects in that gene
So looking at your genetics can be important can affect that conversion and allow cancers to more easily feed off of
lactate
So it's important to look at that, but we do kinesiology testing as well
It's not perfect, but it's a good way to give us clues to know what your cancer's currently feeding off of so that we could take those out of your diet